lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducirlos a un ciclo for y lo voy a
hacer escribiendo un pequeño programa
que calcula el factorial de un número en
caso de que no recuerden lo que es el
factor y'all de un número les diré que
el factorial de uno se escribe
normalmente con el 1 y un signo de
exclamación y está literalmente
significa el factorial de uno que se
evalúa como uno si dicen dos factorial
eso es igual a dos por uno si dicen tres
factorial es igual a tres por dos por
uno lo que es igual a seis así que si
tienen el factor y'all de cualquier
número eso es igual a ese número por el
número anterior por el número anterior y
así sucesivamente hasta uno sabiendo
esto vamos a implementar nuestro
programa de factorial y la manera en que
lo voy a hacer es preguntando al usuario
voy a pedir al usuario que escriba el
número del que quiere saber el factorial
y entonces lo voy a calcular y lo voy a
hacer usando una función que payton
provee estoy usando python 2
en este vídeo hay una pequeña diferencia
que mencionaremos en un momento por si
acaso están usando python 3
payton 2 tenía más implementaciones en
el momento en que se hizo este vídeo
pero ya hay una versión de payton tres
círculos que es una versión más nueva
lo voy a aclarar en un vídeo posterior
pero vamos a continuar tomaré la entrada
del usuario y lo voy a hacer mediante un
prompt que muestre un mensaje teclea un
número entero
que no sea negativo para calcular el
factorial
y lo que estamos haciendo es pasar un
argumento a la función input y el
argumento que estamos pasando a la
función impute es este string y un
string suena como algo muy complicado
pero en realidad es sólo una cadena de
caracteres lo podemos ver como un montón
de texto la función presentará este
texto en un cuadro de diálogo para que
el usuario ponga algo y evaluará lo que
se tecleo en ese cuadro de diálogo
entonces podrán tener el número que
teclea el usuario en una variable o
podrán tener una variable que se refiere
al número que tecleo el usuario
dependiendo de la manera en que quieran
visualizar las variables si están usando
python 3 tendrán que usar la función
evans para lo que la función input les
regrese en este momento estoy usando
python 2 y si quieren hacer esto
exactamente de la manera en que yo lo
estoy haciendo estoy usando el país
script er y del entorno de desarrollo
integrado es gratis un proyecto de
código abierto y estoy usando una pc
pero hay muchas maneras en que pueden
programar en python en realidad pueden
cualquier editor de texto bueno ya hemos
leído la respuesta del usuario y la
pusimos en esta variable número y lo que
es padre de payton es que podemos correr
este programa así como esta y ver lo que
pasa lo voy a salvar y lo voy a correr
este pequeño cuadro de diálogo corre en
este entorno de desarrollo integrado y
el pronto muestra el string que
escribimos teclea un número entero que
no sea negativo para calcular el
factorial así que voy a teclear un
número digamos pies y hago clic en ok y
no pasa nada claro que no pasa nada
porque no escrito nada en el programa
pero si tecleo número podemos ver que
está asignado a 10
la variable número se está refiriendo al
número 10 así que ahora podemos usar
este número y calcular su factorial y lo
que haremos lo haremos interactivamente
en un momento más hablaré de lo que esto
significa voy a definir otra variable
llamada producto y voy a inicializar
producto con 1 y lo que voy a hacer
con 1 y hasta el valor que la variable
número tenga voy a multiplicar el valor
del producto por el valor de cada número
sucesivo así que voy a empezar
definiendo un ciclo for aquí y en otro
vídeo voy a explicar detalladamente lo
que hace un ciclo force y en este ciclo
fort voy a definir la variable i y es
una variable típica para usar en el
ciclo four y esta variable se irá
incrementando cada vez que entremos al
ciclo fort así que ford y range en
python el ciclo for es un poco diferente
que si lo hacen en javascript en otro
vídeo veremos cómo se hace pero
adquiriremos range de número y solo para
que entiendan lo que la función range
hace provee una lista de números
empezando de cero hasta el número que
indicamos menos uno aquí definimos la
variable número número es 10 entonces si
decimos range este número me regresa a
una lista que empieza en 0 y hasta 9 o
sea 10 menos 1 y es lo mismo que si
hacemos
de 10 y lo que este ciclo for hace es
asignar a la variable y cada término de
la secuencia empezando por 0 y haciendo
todo lo que le digamos en el ciclo y
asignando luego 1 a y luego 2 luego 3 y
así sucesivamente hasta que pasemos por
todos los elementos de la lista entonces
lo que podemos hacer aquí es mientras se
está ejecutando el ciclo fort podemos
redefinir la variable producto igual al
valor anterior de producto por lo voy a
multiplicar por y + 1 esto lo voy a
explicar paso a paso en otro vídeo pero
ahora quiero que piensen en lo que está
pasando
digamos que el número es 3 producto es
inicial izado con 1 y decimos for y en
range de 3 aquí hacemos range de 3
entonces iba a ser 0 y vamos a tomar el
valor anterior del producto que es uno
por y más 1 y vale 0 1 es 1 así que uno
por uno es igual a 1 después vamos a
asignar ahí el siguiente valor de la
lista que es 1 esto es lo que el ciclo
for hace en cada iteración incrementa el
valor de y cambia el valor de y
asignando cada elemento de esta lista la
siguiente vez en el ciclo el producto es
igual a 1 y el valor de y es 1 así que
uno más uno es 2 por 1 es igual a 2
después en la siguiente iteración y es
igual a 2 así que dos más uno es igual a
tres por producto que en la última
iteración de la igualados dos por tres
es igual a seis cuando terminamos con el
ciclo por la variable producto hace
referencia al factorial del número que
leímos del usuario así que podríamos
decir imprime producto print producto
en python cuando llegamos a este punto
sabe que debe salir del ciclo for cuando
ha asignado todos los elementos de la
lista a y esa es la razón por la que no
corre para siempre este ciclo for vamos
a ver si esto que escribimos aquí
funciona realmente dejen de escribir
esta instrucción de esta manera y vamos
a ver si funciona déjenme salvarlo y
correrlo me está pidiendo que teclee un
número entero que no sea negativo para
calcular el factorial tratemos con 3 y
me da la respuesta correcta
hagámoslo nuevamente teclea un número
entero que no sea negativo para calcular
el factorial tratemos con algo más
grande 10 función o asumiré que lo van a
verificar ustedes mismos lo que hemos
hecho aquí es un programa muy simple
pero era algo necesario calcular el
factorial de un número en otro vídeo
revisaremos paso a paso el ciclo fort
por si acaso han tenido alguna confusión
así que esperen un vídeo con una
explicación cuidadosa del ciclo for